remember stupid voices and funny faces
are working local the people watching
your videos okay
hello everybody my god mark really yes
really or the middle they can--it ugly
face good I'm gonna start it before that
don't you forget you mister I'm in
control here I could kill you with the
thought and a swing of this axe but I'm
not going to because we're gonna work
together and cooperate so hello
everybody my name is markiplier and I'm
back with 7 days to die with my good
buddy Wade hi yo today I'm good good
that's all you got to describe what
describe ya about how you're feeling
show me your feelings one no who's that
what are you doin ever mind no one wants
to hear your feelings wait but we are
back it's been a while since we recorded
this um had like three weeks or
something it's been a while wait it oh
yeah but we're back into it we have
managed to pick up right where we left
off and hopefully there are no doggy's
down in this mind I look so cuz all my
stuff is in storage so I'm gonna get all
out yeah you spend some time getting
down I'm gonna dig some stuff out now as
you guys recall we're in the middle of
building a farm and I'm gonna dig this
mine some more for more stone and
whatnot but we're just we're doing a
pretty good job so far on what we got
right wait I think so no good is up man
compared to what people thought was
gonna happen which was that we're gonna
die very quickly which not bad get out
our skills
hey doubt ours well they doubt your
skills and for good reason but lemme it
made you have no skills and you are
varied outta below okay yeah I looks
Greek for something to do with like some
kind of salad dressing that would be
Caesar dressing and no we're not talking
about salads we're where are our
conversations are a little more highbrow
than early dinner delicacies why are we
talking about eyebrows eyebrows who's
talking about eyebrows you just said our
conversations a little bit more eyebrows
well I remember why we didn't record a
lot for a while it's in I got like
tolerate certain person weights hammer
it is just
humor is just so hilarious that you
can't tolerate it for more than a few
seconds without wanting to kill yourself
and that's because you can't stand the
funny it's too funny it's almost too
funny Wayne I know oh well yeah yeah
yeah we're back and we're waiting for it
to be day it's um we got back in here
and we forgot that we stopped at 6:30 in
the morning currently now where you are
maybe it is where you if it's 6:30 in
the morning where you are rate comment
and subscribe write in the comments
below about how raisins is at your time
where you are subscribe to me instead no
don't don't do it it's a trap ha ha ha
ha ha ha what you got going on up here
uh there was a hole there's a hole over
here and a hole but I put it in the
wrong place but yeah all they destroyed
our backpack
oh wait what they destroyed the backpack
that used to be on top of this
nightstand in one hit was there anything
in it [ __ ]
think so ok good there better not have
been weight or else it'll be your butt
on the line never know if there was cuz
it's destroyed down you can't go back
and watch the videos I mean oh you're
right again for the first time weight is
not recording this because he's got a
big stock pile of stuff and he's too
important to be bothered by such
trivialities as you guys wait really
hates you guys is what I'm trying to say
god dammit wait why do you hate them
they give you so much love you said some
mean things what did I say by the top of
the beef stick what are you talking
about beef sticks no one is talking
about beef sticks wait that's the way
the old saying goes if you halt if you
hold your beasts beef stick sideways
don't put it in your mouth that's what
the old saying it sideways your beef I
have a speech impediment
you know this Wade well I didn't know
this cuz you just developed it like
overnight ha ha ha ha shut up Wade I you
know I do I can't say my food and soon
there's joy what a matter the nurse
giving you a hard time bar well can you
not handle this nastiness
manski I just got scared by the Oh nose
my mouse was making because I didn't
know I was making it it was a pretty
nice noise they're happy okay
oh I'm out of ammo I am out of ammo no
not oh I am oh we might need to scavenge
some ammo or craft it real soon because
let's let this dog food we eat the dog
food what is this the karma lost on our
lab our Shenoy I don't speak German that
was not German it was left French
everybody who rents we're French not the
French oui oui oui
in your face I am thinking that what too
far oh ah God why you got your humor I'm
sorry was that elses skies blue
Chloe relax no no you had a whole set I
know I didn't know where I put everybody
go no no no no no no no no no you're not
doing that to me I just dug up some iron
in it vanished what it vanished it was
just here now it's gone
where'd it go oh look if I knew that I
wouldn't be asking you be honest no
one's gonna know what you're screaming
about you just randomly I fell off the
deck really okay you continue building
the farm oh there it is it was just
stuck in the wall look at all this or oh
my godness cannon outside cannon outside
no I can't look like yes Ganondorf
Canada Mort
hand off canned off the marais canned
off the fray canned off the fray was an
awesome band it's better than that other
lead singer John Jackson of the yeah
cantaloupe áfive or or dawn dawn mayor
don't even get me started on pelvis
Presley oh I'm so funny hahaha you laugh
at your own jokes you're so funny
you think I'm funny but I am
you think i'm ham but i'm baloney well
uh you-you-you think you're full of
baloney but you're right you think
you're rice put your oh Roni ah that
one's kind of funny but I mean it's not
bad
I got potassium nitrate what did I do
with that uh that makes gunpowder and
it's uh something else yeah farming it's
used for farming and things like
fertilizer yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah boy
yeah boy yeah boy whoa whoa are you okay
there Wade what happened I
I got baritone got baritone oh my god
that's incurable are you gonna be all
right
Oh Oh what just happened I thought I was
flying upward but the deck just
collapsed downward oh it collapsed you
ass why did you let it collapse just
just a part of it oh how much a part of
it this is our farm this is our future
like three blocks this is how we're
gonna sustain our baby with Wade didn't
tell Wade I'm pregnant
in case anyone at home remembers I'm a
woman a strong independent woman who
don't need no man by Wade
you need me I don't need you I'd survive
much better without you I'm gonna go
find someone named Shane and make a baby
with unprotected sex eagles Mexico's
sexy I said that wha Leo remember in
that episode that I thought was never
gonna air cuz it was so bad you know the
one that the one that aired yeah yeah I
did the whole thing unedited I loved it
I didn't even look like I didn't think
it was gonna show up you don't watch my
videos no oh I do actually I was rude
you're out last yeah yeah oh yeah okay
you should play that game it's fun I
watched like the first five minutes of
your first episode I was just like nope
oh really oh really cause it was so
scary and you were just a big baby II am
Nisha
wait wait wait wait look I'm dropping
down some more stone for you baby oh
well thank you I call you baby after the
name I gave my baby baby baby I named my
baby baby well it's a
redneck of you shut up don't make fun of
my baby baby actually don't make fun of
my baby baby I shouldn't
it's mean you shouldn't you're mean to
my baby it's your baby baby - baby is
it's your bells would it be some zombie
hang no zombie
especially not with unprotected sex
Eagles no way what do you think I am
some sort of trailer trash no Ronald ray
all support Oh Scooby what are you doing
here written raha as ceremonious two
hour seven days should I play through
something is in my eye and it hurts
really badly
seriously yeah it's happening again well
it's time it's happened to you before I
know it happened to me the first time
then it happened to you I don't happen
to be me this game and some about it I'm
tearing up people in who are watching in
HD could I've got that accent now and I
can't get rid of it we're watching in HD
people who are watching in HD can tell
that I'm seriously crying in my right
eye that's too bad
that's too bad I was making fun of y'all
my mash with his Britain hee-haw talk
and now I'm making fun of myself I had
to talk to y'all me mash since we did
that but they're drunk just divas are
the pirate Hershel from back before did
it he did it Fossum estab their pirate
heart
it doesn't sound a dingdong damn thing
like us does the Hershel right now I'm
up oh no no pie round here I'm on kills
the deer yeah you okay doggy on the run
I killed the dog II got elastin there's
a good things attitude didn't stutter he
okay there you don't say attitude to too
good
uh-oh what's going on with you gigging
you the disco remix of my voice really
there's no remix so get data bingo or
you think you're wrong but you're in
love
what's that noise it was a dead deer
it's deadly I heard like the sound of
nine oh there's a doggy chasing this
deer haha oh there's a moose man noise
some breakfast Wafi it excuse me that's
what he said to me once the moose man
yeah the moose man said that to you I
think so
really are you sure about that you don't
seem lucky know what you're taking by it
really traumatized me one time and I
think I'm just blocking it out wait how
still how did i traumatize you
no no moose man did oh okay yeah yeah
those wasn't in the first playthrough
you did on your tail
Andy huh yeah I think it was it's not a
bad way to start I mean that's how I
started this was the first horror game
I've ever played
oh yeah you you haven't played any other
horror games like that there's a rabbit
in the house I'm gonna blame him
oh yeah I'm gonna blame ma we got again
do you remember Pam yeah what you ever
playing in ez do you remember there was
a part where like the moose man standing
guarding the way you got to go yet to
throw a rock to distract this yeah that
was all that was one of the best parts
those amazing well here's the thing I
got that far through the rock direction
and then uh I was running past him and I
heard him roar but I thought it was
coming from in front of me so I turned
around trying to run another I ran right
into it I felt like PETA do you handle
her very well only apparently not
because I I had to stop playing it for
that episode I've only had that happen
once to me before I mean over time I
build up with dollars to horror games
that's why you know I really am picky
about the ones I play now and I want
like that big scares I play with super
max volume and really dark but you know
I I really really got scared on an
amnesia custom story called lacasa where
I had to stop playing and also vanished
and other stuff dread halls I think so
what happened in lacasa Lacaze it was it
was I don't know what it was I played
the entire game and it was like uh
SEPA sewed game all in row and it got so
bad that I just I literally felt like I
was gonna die in real life for some
reason ah like how I was about I was
about to fall apart
I was literally losing my mind and
Alston is just like I couldn't do it
anymore I had to go I had to go I had to
go I had to go couldn't take it yeah
who's bad who's that agree it was that
scary like no joke it wasn't even that
like it was that scary by itself it was
just that you know I I couldn't I
couldn't handle it I was like I was just
not enough for it I'm gonna build like
outer walls though that we can fill it
dirt in the middle of it okay is that
what you had in mind yeah so slathering
would for okay I got wood here so I'm
kind of doing it myself
okay the hell happened to this part why
is this all wonka fide what I don't know
Oh weird I I don't like the way that
sometimes Eve's placed on uniformly rly
I'm uniformly really you know onion lair
alone uniformly really in the way that
they learn alaria but a game it's
getting dark outside wait I know
I'm just putting up a little out of rim
so then there spiders damn bees can't
get up to is lighter than bees
I hate them spiders am bees they're my
least favorite fleeced my favorite shut
your mouth I don't care what you think
about my English I'm a talk Paul you
don't tell don't you dare tell Paul
don't you dare tear apart or tell him
don't you dare tell tell pop I've been
telling my baby baby on you I'm told you
know your baby baby or else I'll tell
Paul that you told your baby baby and
I'll tell Paul about the tear and okay
we did baby I'm gonna make this here
middle [ __ ] dark and sad I'm gonna light
it up real good our only real threat out
hair should be them there the Hornets
Hornets what does a Hornet
flying bug wasp thing they're horny is
just like you were when we made this
baby with unprotected sex achill I
didn't know I was involved in the making
it's your baby girl you were involved
probably on the moonshine you were on
the movie shot not drinking it but
hey speaking in the moonshine I see it
we should get all in stagnant uh oh I'll
hear them I hear them I hear the harem
of them well that what what the what
they gonna do I don't know what I what
is they gonna do they're gonna try to
break inside and keyless that probably
they're gonna do is whisk in sunfish of
this rear episode I agree as that a damn
uncle okay then
alright so thank you all so much for
watching stick around after the credits
for the net scene if you want to we've
been doing that okay
okay how are we gonna survive this uh
very carefully I don't know uh what are
you building in the middle of there what
is that ports the ports for what we put
a roof on it so it doesn't collapse why
would it collapse because this game is
very weird about needing support systems
why would it need support on top of the
area that it would not collecting it
here aren't we I thought we were
building it right here on this level
yeah out here right yeah so what are
those supports for for a roof why would
we need a roof so we can go and deal
with the farm at night not to worry
about Hornets getting to us oh I guess
all right then fine you do your thing
you do your thing I'm gonna go who's
gonna uh we're done with the crazy
voices there unless you really want to
keep it
that's just my voice haha really now is
it just your voice it is what are you
gonna do what you can't talk anymore I
don't know my pickaxe is almost broke
that's a bad thing yeah it is but I got
lots of iron I've got um Oh floppy you
always make a different noise every time
out puppy shows up you make a different
screen I respect that about you I
respect that a lot I don't try and buy a
lot I mean I don't respect it at all
I don't honey then how did you get in
there's a window upstairs that I got in
but a puppy can't get in through that
did it come through the basement I
haven't filled it in
probably yeah I'll just keep an eye on
it wait a minute this baby this is baby
baby baby yeah the baby the what the
baby seem to have come from upstairs
I'll just block it off with some wood
that way we can easily break it once we
need to get out and do the day opener
today Oh what do we even have anything
to plant no no yes we do we had potato
seeds where I had him I found him I got
him in my inventory I've got five
potatoes yeah well that's good yeah see
we weren't building it for nothing we're
not stupid morons we're doing big dumb
idiot we're not this have you been stuck
around in the air before we're not
totally idiots
trying to make their way through the
world without thinking about what
they're doing
I'm glad that's not us that is not us we
are better than that and by better I
mean we're now really better than that
but we're better than that
yay we're not better than that I like
backhanded compliment support for
ourselves pat on the back it wasn't even
a compliment in no way was that supposed
to be reassuring to anything that one
would feel reassured you want some meat
you want to eat this meat
I would love some meat in my mouth where
are you let me put my meat in your mouth
I'm beating this here Rock where's here
middle oh you got metal that's good I
got more metal but I also got meat you
want to eat my meat yeah we need to cook
that there me no we can't cook it we
just got to eat it raw that's all we got
so stick it in your mouth raw and we'll
get to it okay
hear it thank you
why are you throwing so much me cuz I
have I was like thirty meat I got a lot
of meat just so you know I got a lot of
my love putting this here raw meat in my
mouth sickle your mouth sickle Oh later
we can bang with unprotected mouse
tickles
for me it'll be delicious I was hoping
you would say that mm-hmm okay anyway so
it's 3:00 a.m. and the house is jumpin
jumpin way do you leave your van at home
copyrighted song can be soon we're not
recorded I am recorded right now because
I guess I or do arty Norden ha ha ha ha
I don't think I don't think that it was
even close enough to do anything of the
sorts way do you leave your doll oh oh
there's like the southern version of
whatever the hell we were doing I don't
know what that was for turning a
Maronite now maintaining in my room my
companion and we oh don't dig too deep
that's when the doggies came from down
here just stick laterally oh ok and take
a minecraft style digging so like
digging one row I think that'll work out
better ok
is that was it was that was that was
that was that was
what are you do it hmm
what what are you talking to you what is
what are you making noises about I
didn't do a thing what are you talking
about your leg was that was that was
that was that was no I don't think I
remember seeing any of that well seeing
what what see what see what I you're
confusing me
well stop being confused and then you
won't be confused anymore to man
surviving with you is a crazy experiment
yes it's a courageous charisma to Kurama
no still ominous actor ramen noodle I am
an Eaton karaman noodle and forever I've
never really done it
you never eat ramen I don't know what
that's exit this is I'm not sure either
but you've never eaten ramen I don't
really think so
well alright then Robin is a noodle from
the agent lands that is cheap
and slightly nutritious slightly
locklear nutritious stuff the nutritious
develo keeps you laughing dire times of
horrible nature 'no strany who's mr.
Haney I don't reckon that is from that
Leave It to Beaver thing that I don't
know about I don't think so sir sir who
you called sir
I think I'm calling you sir mister not
Haney that I always called the name of
the guy third are you okay you don't
seem too right in the head and once
again the iron that I cut up disappeared
you know if I ever did seem right the
head you should have been more concerned
if I they're probably right there ain't
she you are the most right you've ever
been you're kind of combining southern
with scoobadood oh you ain't never been
no right - never nobody you never
yeah out here yeah anyway I've got a lot
of iron I've got um forty six iron
ingots and nine lead ingots oh no I
never mind I've got 27 let ingots so
I've got a lot of stuff I'm gonna check
to see if upstairs is still cure it's
not I'm just getting it happen it is I'm
trying to freak you out but it didn't
work and oh you were told all is it up
there so I didn't care haha barricade
myself well jeez I see what your
priority is now by the way oh I got so
much iron
it's just ridiculous I've got I've got
loads and loads and loads and loads of
iron I have a little bit I've got loads
of iron what do you want to do with it I
can tour it know where I can make
gunpowder how do I make gunpowder it
says I can make gunpowder oh I can make
gunpowder holy crap I can what's it take
it's a potassium nitrate and coal which
I don't think is quite correct but it's
day there it is oh yeah cadet gunpowder
too weird okay well there we go I've got
40 gunpowder well good enough for 20 and
I can make a hub cat landmine dude how
do I do that I don't know never made one
I don't have any hub caps how can you
make the land without two hubcaps I
don't know I can make a tin landmine I'm
gonna make a tin like oh ten can wait no
hang on I got an idea
mom be it be it nobody must last words
uh Hill Oh yo ha ha ha know that scrap
metal I don't want to make Scrabble
oh my ex gosh you ever see a goofy movie
yeah the first one I have I love that
movie 9 9 loans but that was one of my
favorite I never saw any the other ones
I only saw the first one okay fun either
way it's time to leave for the night
thank you all for watching this the
after show oh wait it's all being
recorded yeah
course yeah Rosales yeah so anyway I
forgot you did this